今天台股開高走低
跌了210點
46000是壓力嗎
哲哲 你的台灣50
一下子就賺了1300萬了
那現在你要走了嗎
好多人好擔心這個事情
第二個 台灣股市最強EPS群聯
全台灣股市1800多檔股票
公布了EPS好到要命
結果為什麼今天公布EPS之後快跌停
110多元 第二季EPS這麼漂亮
第三個 國巨也大跌6%
被動元件完了嗎
這一波反彈就結束了嗎
Love is over了嗎
愛結束了嗎
今天獨家跟大家報告
這些獨家的飆股
以及台股的盤勢
台股今天有點開高走低
最後跌了210點
收跌在45811點
雖然有點開高走低
投資長還是有股票表現不錯
好戲登場的精材
股價一度大漲超過5%
準備再創近期新高
另外投資朋友們
都很關心記憶體的群聯
明明最新財報顯示
第二季EPS就高達118元
直接榮登台股最高
也就是說他是上市櫃
1800多家中最會賺錢的公司
但為什麼今天卻打到快跌停
到底發生什麼事了
最強EPS的股價都不支倒地
是不是代表台股這波反彈就結束了呢
你想知道投資長是怎麼看的嗎
接下來就交給我們
經濟日報選股冠軍
單季188%的紀錄保持者
同時也是全台灣唯一百萬粉絲
最受歡迎的分析師
郭哲榮投資長 投資長好
Lily 各位投資朋友大家好
今天台灣股票真的慘兮兮
你看一下這個群聯
這個走勢圖真的很扯
哲哲 怎麼會這樣子
8299群聯第二季的EPS 118元
給你這樣殺下去
投資朋友 這一波他也沒反彈多少
今天爆量
這種EPS
頂多他有瑕疵說
毛利率不可能一直那麼高
人家潘CEO講話這麼實在
你有必要這麼誇張嗎
投資朋友 有人算了
航運股來了 4倍本益比
我覺得完全不一樣
航運股頂多好個1 2年
記憶體會好很久
我昨天用那個託管推論
引來很多的響應 回應
說哲哲你真厲害
你完全知道AI以後怎麼運用
我講的只是其中運用之一
以後會越來越多公司
用新的AI 新的運用
你要去了解這些東西
所以記憶體
就像我講的語音客服這一塊
尤其語音含語音客服這一塊
只要克服一些保密資訊的情況之下
他會用託管推論
請人家選出
做出最好的程式來
語音程式 針對我這家銀行
各行各業其實都需要客服
如果客服這個成本非常低
為什麼不付呢
所以我要告訴大家
每一家公司都需要AI改進系統
你們不理我 我沒有辦法
今天群聯會覺得
怎麼會這樣子
EPS 群聯
EPS給了承諾
股價卻選擇分手
哲哲今天又變成
又化身為愛情大師了
EPS給了承諾
第二季EPS 118元
獨占鰲頭
可是股價卻選擇分手
怎麼這樣
他很完美 結果對方卻不夠愛他
怎麼會這樣子
對啊 為什麼
好像愛情
這個有時候就跟愛情一樣
不可理喻
你不用想那麼多
是你的就是你的
我認為他是好的標的 好的對象
好不好
只要這個趨勢沒有改變
他的身體健康沒有改變
還是會為你做牛做馬賺錢的好不好
這個股市
說到這個國巨呢
很多人國巨被套牢
我一直跟大家講
我有沒有講過一件事
這一波最高快要700塊對不對
我說國巨800元之前
比較不會有壓力
可是到800元壓力會越來越大
你現在就覺得有點壓力
國巨我另外送大家
等一下
國巨對不對
我另外送大家一句話
什麼一句話
國巨今天反彈
國巨在這邊 我今天準備了
很多人被套牢
其實套牢有時候股票要走
有時候套牢不是真愛
只是你不甘心而已
你本來就該走 你也知道
可是你就是不甘心
套牢住你的不是真愛
只是你不甘心
股市如愛情
有些股票你知道你不甘心
你就該走
有些股票你知道這是真愛
不是不甘心 你心甘情願
那你就套著吧
那國巨 1200的國巨
我覺得目前不是你的真愛
500多塊
4 500多塊
跟我一起買的國巨
那是真愛
不好意思 那不一樣
你懂不懂 懂
巴菲特90幾歲 身價上兆元
不是你的真愛
如果巴菲特來個30幾歲
身價5000億元
不好意思 那就是你的真愛
不同的年紀 不同的價格
1200的國巨不是你的真愛
你有1200 你現在被套牢了
你只是不甘心而已 不是真愛
你要找我
那怎麼 有一種方式 降低成本
1200買一個 對不對
500元買一個
平均成本850元
那就有機會怎麼樣
就有機會反彈成功到850 是
到這邊850你就有機會了
那這個真愛
就有機會持續彈下去這個愛情了
好不好
我也講一句難聽的話
你當台灣股市
台灣股市已經漲得很誇張了
休息一下怎麼樣
你就受不了
國巨也彈了35% 你們受不了
那個群聯我們昨天算了一下
也漲了47%
所以你們覺得天天V轉
這個已經算是真的V轉了
台灣股市大盤
我在這邊買進
每天漲
今天回檔一天你受不了
又不是回檔到這邊 是不是
不會 不要嚇到你好不好
所以平常心好不好
有人說哲哲像愛情大師
我今天就稍微講個愛
股市如愛情的故事 好不好
大家好 我是哲哲
應該沒有人不認識我 來
8299是真愛嗎
是啊
不是真愛的話
那就變成i珍食了 好不好 來
從大一看投資長
看到讀博士了
哲哲皮膚怎麼越來越好
可以開一集講怎麼保養的嗎
很簡單 花錢保養
花錢就好嗎
花錢 還要運動
身心靈 是
非常注重睡眠
哲哲在大概30
33 35歲之前
睡眠睡得像豬一樣
現在很淺眠
但是還是會強迫自己
盡量要睡7個小時
只要睡好
其實我看很多的疾病
然後就會好很多
睡好 然後不要太胖
基本上你就會少一半以上
幾千種的疾病 好不好 OK
是你不甘心
下次我們唱
有沒有是你不甘心這首歌
每天喜歡看哲哲和Lily 謝謝大家
今天很平靜
華碩很強 好不好 OK
來 我跟大家講
會怕的退出股市
股市 來
現在國巨可以續抱
8299真愛
跟愛情一樣往上
來 愛情沒有一定往上的好不好
來 我們來看一下這些東西
所以今天
就其實今天已經把重點講得差不多
就是漲那麼多
這個漲了差不多
昨天算漲了30幾%
反彈跌一下還好啦
反覆測底才是正確的
本來這個講實在話
這一波反彈
我本來就知道會上5萬點
我昨天不是說8月5萬點比較難
本來就很難了好不好
反覆測底
為什麼反覆測底 你看喔
大盤對不對
你看大盤已經挑戰前高了
是不是 沒錯吧
前高這邊都
動不動都是
1.5兆的成交量
你現在這邊有沒有看到
這邊頭部一堆套牢賣壓
所以你在這邊本來就有一個
權值股的賣壓 是
權值股賣壓有時候會引發
中小型個股的賣壓
這樣懂不懂
Understand 好不好
所以群聯這些會被影響到
平常心就好 好不好
你只是要分清楚
誰是真愛 誰不是真愛
哲哲第二手 連發
第二個名言連發
真愛值得長抱
爛股只會長套
不是漲套 是長套
真愛值得長抱
爛股只會長套
你只要分清楚它是真愛
還是不是真愛
就好了 好不好 OK嗎
分不清楚真愛的話
你就只能吃i珍食
就是那個7-11
晚上的時候比較便宜的食物
i珍食也沒什麼不好
好不好 來
沒有 投資長分不出來的話
就要來找投資長了
真的要來找投資長了 好不好
不錯 你今天講話氣勢很棒
開頭講的也不錯
來 我們來看一下
看一下這些東西
慢慢來看這些股票
先來看一下我們的AI的圖
等我一下 AI圖
群聯我們看一下
我們看一下群聯很重要
因為群聯118
187耶 你霸氣 霸氣啦
你霸氣 有沒有看到 真的霸氣
合併營收1000多億有沒有看到
60元大躍進
60元也還好啦 好不好
因為現在股價2000多元
今天已經變
今天變多少 看一下
不到2000元喔
有 還是有 2080
所以這一波漲很多
我前陣子才看他不到2000元
懂我的意思嗎 來
所以拉回很正常
來 稅後純益
第二季EPS 118元有沒有看到
也是破紀錄好不好
存貨天數從315天
下降到297天
也算不錯
存貨價值也算不錯
毛利率增加到65.3%
可是他有說毛利率不可能那麼高
這沒什麼不好 OK嗎
好不好 OK
NAND產能補上最快要4年
4年有沒有看到 4年
慢慢漲
這4年期間喔 來
你就會看到
因為群聯最大的問題
記憶體最大問題是已經炒完一波了
環球晶還不算炒一波
到時候這4年我覺得
記憶體有機會再漲
更有機會漲的是矽晶圓
因為記憶體上游需要矽晶圓
成熟製程也需要
你會看到矽晶圓到時候慢慢噴
1000 2000
不要說我沒說
我再強調一件事情
漲你也不敢買 跌你也不敢買
退出股市算了
真的退出股市算了
哲哲今天講那麼多愛情的股市
是要告訴你
股市如愛情 你知道嗎
不要去管那些生活上的小吵小鬧
重點是這檔股票適不適合你
你不知道
找我這個愛情大師
我來幫你 這樣懂不懂
我幫你解套 好不好
解套有兩種
一種是讓你股價上去
另一種是你幫他
你就跟他解除關係
就這麼簡單 OK嗎
我們來看一下
今天廣達也是很誇張
十倍不到的本益比
所以台股哪有什麼泡沫
投資朋友
結果今天給你漲2.5元
你不覺得很扯
昨天看一下10.9倍本益比 對不對
所以你看這些的財報
我們來看一下 做AI圖
真的 我再講一件事
我隨便一個手機
現在就有可以模擬95%的AI客服了
而且你聽不出來真假
我昨天是很興奮
你好 中華電信客服
呵呵 他還跟你呵呵
有點三八
你可以叫他穩重
你可以設定權重
設定他的個性 屬性
通通都可以
以前是很難
所以這些AI投資語音 投資差很多
還有AI線上客服
還有現在
也不需要去什麼補習班學習
他講英文
比外國人講英文更標準
還會糾正你的語法
你懂不懂 是
你要找一個外國人
有教學經驗的
不用 他會糾正你的語法
什麼過去式 過去分詞
都有機會教你
你懂不懂我的意思
都一樣 語音學習也是很大一塊
來 我們來看一下
上市櫃的EPS超越戰
有沒有看到
緯穎 2025年275元
緯穎是275元有沒有看到 有
我告訴你
群聯光一季就118元扯不扯
真的很誇張
群聯這樣子187元
上半年累計
群聯超車 有沒有看到
贏緯穎
緯穎今年也進步很多是不是 156
所以群聯現在是怎麼樣
已經是股王
應該說他享有股王的EPS
但沒有股王的股價
你懂不懂我的意思
好像變成德不配位 怎麼這樣
這個報表做得很漂亮
你看這也是用AI做的
AI可以取代非常多的獲利
然後SanDisk
跟他有合作關係有沒有看到
他還說要去買那些庫藏股
是不是要推升股價 是
他揭2030年的一個成長
都是說4年後有沒有看到
毛利率可望守穩80%
有沒有看到
他講80%算很高了
所以他直接講
營收有沒有
調整後的營業利率
跟自由現金流量50%有沒有看到
他在布局AI推論市場
推動HBF
推論 訓練完以後要推論
你每次 一個程式來
你每次要跑一個結論的時候
這叫推論
這就需要記憶體 你懂不懂
而且是瞬間的推論
是需要記憶體
因為你不用它的時候
它就不會用推論了 是不是
我Gemini放著的時候
同一時間我們每個人用的時候
比如說昨天3點一到
台北市開始有網路的時候
我們同時用Gemini
不好意思 這就需要
可能要很多的記憶體 你懂不懂
我們同時用 懂不懂
這叫推論好不好
訓練的時候是
我訓練這個AI程式
這個程式
下一代出現之前我要訓練它
也是需要記憶體 OK嗎
只是它主要的是
要布局推論的市場
這樣O不OK
大概聽得懂就好
講那麼多你聽不懂
聽太懂也沒有意義
我不是有些人
喜歡把它講得太複雜
好不好 這個跟大家講
最近也有人 我講一下
因為哲哲真的很紅
最近有人找我
蠻多券商 投信要找我業配
今天哲哲在此先跟大家講
不好意思得罪大家
哲哲不太收業配
第一個 我真的不缺這個錢你知道
第二個 我一講業配
我怕收這一次業配以後
以後我講話就不太公平
我也講
我不管我的
我不管你怎麼看我
我不敢說我是百分之百的完人
我不敢說
有時候會不小心闖個黃燈
或怎麼樣
這個我不敢說
可是投資的誠信
我倒是很高標準
投資的誠信
我是非常高標準
因為你們繳錢給我
最在乎的是我的投資誠信
所以我盡量不接業配就不接業配
不好意思 最近很多人投信找我
當然我也不想得罪他們
其實你看我有說
富邦的00662 是不是
我覺得這個不錯
如果你要分散台灣風險
我自己本身覺得不錯
我覺得很不錯
我不想要因為
我拿了錢才說不錯
那現在很多人業配
是因為拿了錢才說不錯
然後可能嘴巴跟你說
因為我有試用過
我覺得有點順序顛倒
一定是我自己覺得不錯
我才會跟你講
記得這件事
我的本身
比如說我之前推薦一個便當
火之舞不錯
我跟老闆也算熟
我是真的覺得還不錯吃
我一定要發自內心覺得不錯
我這個沒有辦法拿了錢辦事
如果我不認同的話
所以不好意思
這個也不需要我業配
我真的覺得這檔ETF不錯
我自然會講
這是我的個性 好不好
這個跟大家講
扯遠了 只是說因為蠻多的
先跟大家講一下
當然我覺得
不代表我不收錢去做這個業配
不代表我不會講你的好話
只是我不想因為拿了錢才說好話
這個邏輯要對
好不好 OK嗎
哲哲投資的人設
我覺得誠信很重要
當然不代表別的老師拿錢
就代表他們不好
網紅拿錢代表不好 不予置評
我比較不批評網紅
私底下可能有些擦邊球
推薦股票 收錢
那這個就違法了 好不好
因為這是投顧分析師
才能做的事情
要分析師而且在投顧的分析師
才能做的事情 來
那個廣達的AI伺服器訂單
旺到2028年有沒有看到
所以明年都沒問題 你懂不懂
有沒有看到
毛利率 這是毛利率你看到
一路下滑
所以輝達也是滿狠的
一直砍人家
EPS突然跳升
從5.5到7.43
7.43很厲害
7.43本益比現在不到11倍
差不多10.9到11倍
這麼漂亮的圖 是不是
也是用AI做的
你怎麼會覺得AI
我跟你講
有商業頭腦都會持續投資AI
都會有很多的錢 好不好
現在我跟你講
現在就是一定接下來會有
大家發明很多可以改善
作業流程 我再講一次
公司內部作業流程
每一家公司都需要
因為可以省很多人力
可以用AI來改善
尤其文書作業流程
研發製程的這個作業流程
也可以利用AI來改善
你要記得我這句話
一定都會去用AI
那這些就需要一些推論訓練
而且這些可以賺到錢
光是AI語音客服
銀行業就500億
一年就500億的支出
我就算投資1000億也沒關係
因為我可以省一輩子的人事支出 是
聽懂嗎
還不用給勞健保
還不用給退休金
那沒有辦法
你當老闆一定他們都會這樣想
你懂不懂
不是每個人像我這樣
比較重感覺 重感情
是不是 這個跟大家講
來 所以我們要一個東西
現在還有一個東西
昨天為什麼美國股市也蠻強的
最主要是有開始 有預期
然後Fed升息的機率越來越低了
高盛直接說按兵不動 好不好
7月升息機率降到3成多
有沒有看到
不是 升息機率降到3成多
助理看一下
現在到12月的升息機率多少
升息一碼以上的機率
請助理回答我 好不好
美國銀行說升息一碼
所以有兩家
高盛跟摩根大通都覺得按兵不動
按兵不動對這個是很好的
蠻特別的
那個伊朗
這個控制荷姆茲海峽
結果全世界通膨居然不嚴重
發現全世界的股市跟經濟
滿有韌性的你有沒有發現到
這個跟大家講
下禮拜就是一路走高當沖順勢盤
或是一路走低
請助理提醒我
因為最近賺太多
賺了這個4000點以後
就比較少操作了
因為一口氣就賺100%以上 是
70幾萬好像賺到80萬
70幾萬的保證金賺到80幾萬
這個跟大家講
一路走高 一路走低
來 我們來看一下
那個 不好意思
那個Lily 我們今天來聊天
你那個是 不要是這種語音那麼長
他們會說你像機器人 你信不信
在他們念你之前 我先把你念一下
這樣就為你好
念給他們看 他們就不會念你了
好啦 今天沒事喇低賽而已啦
語氣要記得聽清楚差別
一路走高 一路走低
期貨跟大家講喔 好不好
來 我快笑死了
現在分析師都在轉大人
哲哲天生麗質
不好意思 哲哲天生麗質 謝謝
哲哲是我男神 不錯喔
現在男生女生都喜歡我是不是
謝謝喔 來
哲哲會換iPhone 18嗎
說老實話 我現在比較喜歡
那個如果iPhone的話
我比較喜歡iPhone 18
我想買摺疊機啦
可是我最後可能會換成那個
不是摺疊機
你知道為什麼嗎
因為我現在已經習慣了 你知道嗎
因為我比較注重隱私
我真的很注重我自己的隱私
沒有說手機有什麼特別秘密
但是每個人手機
一定多少都有什麼東西嘛
我不喜歡給人家看到
有時候比如說
我比較沒有安全感
比如說現在都可以用
比如說現在用
你知道嗎 像每一項
比如說我用LINE
在登入之前
LINE本來就可以解鎖對不對 對
在登入之前你還可以用Face ID
每一項也可以用Face ID
你知道喔
照片也可以用Face ID你知道嗎
照片也可以用Face ID 什麼意思
就是你要點進去照片
照片本來就可以保護了
你在進去任何程式之前
你都可以設定用臉部辨識
所以就算你手機是這樣打開來的
你知道嗎
你要點進去重要的項目
APP裡面的話
Face ID還是可以再一層過濾
這樣你懂嗎
這樣不錯啦 你懂不懂
因為有時候它30秒就可以
你可以設定30秒就開始
螢幕就開始鎖定起來
有時候超過30秒
比如說你看下單系統的時候
因為它還在動嘛
它就會超過30秒
可能3分鐘 5分鐘
它螢幕都不會關起來
都不會鎖起來
這時候Face ID就很好用了
好 這扯遠了
結論就是如果是以後
用摺疊手機 用Touch ID的話
你每解鎖 每打開一個APP項目
為了保護你的安全
你還要再用Touch ID
再碰手指頭一次
我感覺蠻麻煩的
我不確定現在Touch ID
夠不夠敏銳
如果夠敏銳的話
那摺疊手機可以換
這樣聽得懂嗎
到時候我要進入一個APP
在保護我的APP
比如說我在照片
我在看清楚的時候
我要點進去照片的時候
不小心螢幕解鎖了 你知道嗎
在點照片的時候
以前要用Face ID
再用一次
人家也看不進去
現在以後你要
變成自己找自己麻煩
你要用指紋再用一次 比較麻煩
這個我跟大家講
哲哲都有研究好不好
中美晶不是真愛了 好不好
回測完就會上47000嗎
回測完會上47000
其實我最討厭那種技術分析的似是而非
你看 股市啊 我告訴你
接下來會打第二隻腳
什麼叫打第二隻腳
有本事要講清楚啊 各位
你懂我的意思嗎
我沒有要批評別人
第二隻腳定義
我覺得除非你是到41000
打這麼深才叫第二隻腳
不然你不要說
回到這邊來就是第二隻腳
你的長短腳也太長太短了吧
你懂不懂
股市震盪再上去
廢話嘛 當然股市震盪再上去是不是
那我問你啊
如果後天就47000了
那這個算震盪嗎
你要說有震盪
你也可以說沒震盪啊 懂不懂
你也可以說沒震盪啊
這樣懂不懂 OK嗎
來 這個跟大家講
想聽歌了
哲哲是不是很少講美股
我幹嘛講美股
我的會員都沒在做美股
不講美股
我已經講了
有啦 講00662已經對你夠好了
是不是 OK
哲哲AI這麼強
Lily 導播會Over嗎
不會啊 你們聽不懂嗎
你們要會用AI
會用AI的Lily 導播
會取代不會用AI的Lily 導播
簡不簡單
Lily就是
假設這是一個主播的位置
這樣懂不懂 懂
南亞今天
下星期48000
我不去預測行情
因為台灣股市真的現在已經是
你看台灣股市要48000很簡單
你記得一件事情
我給你結論好不好
其他分析師不會講
結論就是你不要看費半
不要看
不是不要看費半
就是現在費半
不太可能一下子就16000
不可能創新高對不對 對
很難 不能說不行
它離新高有一段距離有沒有看到
是不是
有一段距離
這麼長的距離對不對 好
那你看喔 日本股市
可是台灣跟日本股市的
相連度沒那麼高
你懂我意思嗎
日本股市離新高比較近一點點
有沒有看到 沒錯吧
是不是 這邊而已 對
這邊而已 到這邊而已
可是問題是日本股市
跟台灣股市的相關係數沒那麼高
韓國股市要死不活的
這麼遠啊
這差太遠了
所以你要韓國股市突破新高
台灣股市一起突破新高
難 短期很難
所以我說喔
剛才費半也是一樣
我說你要看誰
看那斯達克
那斯達克離新高是不是很近 對
新高在這邊
所以那斯達克創新高
台灣股市或許有機會挑戰47000
所以你現在要看那斯達克的指數
那斯達克漲費半也會漲
好不好 這樣懂不懂
那斯達克的指數
這樣懂不懂 Understand
其實台灣股市漲幅
以前是介於那斯達克跟費半之間
那沒關係嘛
我現在不是叫你
突破48000 49000
要47000嘛
所以你要看那斯達克指數
所以回去要認真看那斯達克的指數
好不好
哲哲說我們不要中美晶
我沒有不要中美晶
你不要亂講話 好不好
中美晶今天為什麼還漲
廢話 因為根本之前沒有漲
股市就是來來去去
你們現在會緊張
國巨的唉唉叫都是什麼人
都是套在1000塊以上的國巨的人
500多塊哪有什麼
500多塊的想說
哲哲我應該要再買一次是不是
他會不會回到500塊
你信不信500塊的人這樣想
真的大多數人都這樣想 OK嗎
鴻海
鴻海這個是
就是因為那個財報不夠好
財報很好的都有問題了
更何況財報沒有到非常好
不能說他差喔
沒有資格說他差喔
所以這個股價就這樣就好了
趕快今天
今天會不會很早結束
今天比較無聊盤
有時候
不過我覺得節目
有時候不一定要那麼長好不好
空單8萬多口
不要再說了 那不重要好不好
OK嗎
正價差30點
下禮拜強調一件事喔
下禮拜期貨喔
再講一次 我們看一下喔
當沖順勢盤
開盤 什麼叫一路走高
開盤就是相對低點
開盤就是相對高點
不知道沒關係
大概9點半 9點40你就知道了
這是期貨的走勢 這樣懂不懂
那開盤一路走高呢
我拉回做多就好了
有沒有看到
開盤一路走低呢
我逢高去做空 知不知道
OK嗎 Understand
當沖順勢盤 OK嗎
這個我們來看一下喔
來 所以我們這些東西都一樣
所以哲哲不去事後話 我不去馬後炮
去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
這是我們實在的績效喔
南亞科 欣興 景碩
這是今年的 好不好
聯發科 這是已賣出的績效
還有目前的實在績效 有沒有
環球晶90% 精材78%
我們選比較低的成本 好不好 47%
因為我的會員很多啦
我盡量不去追高啦 好不好
那現在國巨
到今天最高也是31% 好不好
最高的價格來看的話 來
我們來念一下喔
這是技嘉
我們念一下技嘉的簡訊
你來念一下 美女
好 8月14號星期五下午1點45分
恭喜好學生2376技嘉
股價已經連5紅
創下20年多新高
董事長表示本益比被低估
我持續看好他 手上持股獲利續抱
恭喜大家賺錢啦
這個技嘉喔
昨天講說好學生沒講
不要說什麼沒講
有時候他漲跌幅1%以內
我要講什麼 好不好
你要我講我就講啦
技嘉這個走勢很漂亮啊
是不是 技嘉看起來就是要噴出去
技嘉線型很漂亮
我認真看
幸好昨天有人提醒我
這個不錯喔
技嘉不錯喔
仁寶也不錯啦
都是新的做AI伺服器的
之前沒有主攻的這些
仁寶也不錯喔 好不好
仁寶其實本來就該漲了 好不好
現在籌碼比較簡單
仁寶 技嘉這種
AI伺服器的題材的
之前都炒不動的 現在炒動了
你把仁寶 技嘉一起看好不好
記住我這句話好不好
仁寶跟技嘉一起看
在這裡 在這裡好不好
記住我這句話
廣達我有點想買
我覺得廣達有點委屈
助理下禮拜提醒我
要不要買一下
我今天沒有買 好不好
這個新的AI族群
老AI或二線AI
這個跟大家講好不好
那我剛才有請助理
我們再查一下FedWatch
FedWatch也是全台灣
我第一個發現
就是可以告訴你
用插補法算出來升降息機率
12月至少升息1碼67%
所以算
可是如果有銀行
就是我剛才講的
高盛說都不升息
我們再觀察一下
至少9月現在升息機率
比較低了好不好 OK嗎
這個升息很重要
如果一直升息的話
股市是容易崩盤
AI沒有泡沫
只有資金面我怕有泡沫
所以資金面泡沫是說升降息 OK嗎
那我們看一下
現在幾分了
30幾喔
我今天趕快喔
不行 我今天早點結束喔 好不好
看有沒有什麼問題趕快問我
我愛你們好不好
來 廣達下禮拜買
他能到300嗎
十年哥可以夢一下哲哲 什麼意思
來 我都邊聽邊看PTT
很少看聊天室 沒有關係
哲哲 我能相信中美晶嗎
應該可以啦
但是中美晶 環球晶
我還是比較喜歡環球晶
技嘉我買2000張 真的還假的
來炫耀喔
哲哲都沒跟你炫耀
我都沒跟你炫耀我的台灣50買幾張
我有一個更長期的台灣50
所以很多人說哲哲
你這樣子抓轉折
你不如長抱活抱
我本來就有抱很久
我只是要讓你知道
我這一波轉折多會抓而已
39000這邊買 OK
三更半夜不睡覺也要看哲哲
不需要 好不好
你們那個
我下午節目影片就出來了 OK
超久沒說技嘉
不好意思喔
因為最近股票太強了 好不好
哲哲看好精材的法說嗎
精材的法說什麼時候我們看一下
好不好 來
十年哥來喔
十年一遇是不是
在美國是不是
哲哲我愛你
請問力積電連續3天交易量超大
有什麼含意
我們看一下
這個問題我也想知道 我看一下
交易量大
哪有到很大 亂講話
這沒什麼啦
這個大量還好啦 50萬
這邊也大量啊
就大戶來啊
這個量代表大戶
裡面有大戶在做當沖
邊買邊沖他
你懂我的意思嗎 是
邊買邊當沖
400億裡面
可能有100億是在當沖
這樣懂不懂 OK
這樣懂了
所以我說記憶體不用擔心了
你看還是很多大戶在
除了力積電
我比較想買華邦電 好不好
華邦電如果殺下去我想買
你知道嗎 OK嗎
我是認真說的
華邦電我有點想買
華邦電現在買的價格有沒有看到
就跟之前這邊
6月初的價格差不多
有什麼好怕
比這邊還便宜 對耶
是不是 我覺得再下去一點點
我會想買 好不好
不要說哲哲沒有說 好不好
我們看一下還有什麼問題
助理幾分了
是導播幾分了
哲哲真的很帥
跟其他分析師不一樣
看漲說漲 看跌說跌 模稜兩可
我們不要批評別人
但是我就是敢講好不好
我就敢講 來
哲哲可以分析金寶嗎
我分析仁寶就好
金寶 我看一下線型
我覺得仁寶就好了
同一個集團的嘛
你看線圖之前
金寶這邊有拉起來
仁寶也有拉起來
現在仁寶這邊拉起來 金寶沒拉
那很明顯你們還是買仁寶好了
沒錯吧
等一下喔
2324 沒錯吧 你看
前一波金寶有拉 這一波 對
結果這一波金寶在這邊沒拉
很顯然你要買 買仁寶
要買強的股票 好不好
技術線型很重要喔
技術線型不會欺騙你
除非你想要欺騙你自己
這個跟愛情一樣
不適合其實你都知道
是你要不要欺騙自己而已
來 再來看一下
哲哲 世界怎麼看 來
5347世界
華邦電列入名單
有些股票 對
有些列入名單 助理幫我查一下
有些列入名單因為被處置了
反而晚點列入的是哪些股票
台灣的處置股也很特別喔
因為以前比較不會處置到大型股去 對
被列入的比較不會被處置
或處置的不會那麼多
世界先進也是有機會拉起來
這都一樣啦 好不好
因為世界先進跟聯電
都有時候亦步亦趨
聯電最近看起來不行 有沒有看到
聯電最近比想像中弱一點點
都有機會再噴出
因為反彈幅度不多
反彈不到20%
102到121 不到20%
現在121 不到20%
不到20%的股票都有機會噴出去
好不好 OK嗎
這個跟大家講
那我們來看一下 來
禾伸堂下禮拜會翻紅嗎
國巨我覺得下禮拜還是有機會漲
漲的機率比較高
我跟你講800元以上就會有壓力
再給我一次哲哲簽名在書上的機會
我有想要辦演講
但是我覺得辦演講現在應該
3000人場地不好找
我都很臨時的 算了
不好意思喔
你們就是珍惜
看一次珍惜一次好不好 來
請問哲神 台勝科是不是真愛
台勝科當然不是真愛
你看我講的次數就知道
不論他漲跌我也沒講很多次啊
因為之前會員買比較少
我就不想講了 好不好
可是台勝科是裡面最強的
有點小悲哀
就是如果我的股票裡面
中美晶 環球晶 台勝科
這三檔股票裡面
台勝科現在線型最漂亮喔
你不講還好 這個線型才漂亮
這個比力積電線型漂亮
為什麼 因為今天第一個
今天上櫃指數一度是翻黑的
然後你看中美晶跟環球晶對不對
他們今天是
中美晶 環球晶要嘛就跌
要嘛就是小漲而已對不對 對
可是他是剛好噴出
又噴出第一根了
畫歪了
這邊噴出第一根有沒有看到
而且帶量的噴出第一根
所以線型非常之漂亮
所以台勝科目前不是我的真愛
但是他可能是市場的真愛
我不愛他 他去找別人
就這麼簡單
很多人喜歡他 好不好 OK嗎
原本不看分析師的節目
唯獨哲哲一定要看
看久了就知道 哲哲真男人
你久了就知道
我也可以不錄影
我也可以不當分析師
所以看一次少一次 知道嗎
華新科怎麼看
國巨好 華新科就不會差
就這麼簡單 不用看了
7769鴻勁
鴻勁我沒有研究他這麼多基本面
不好意思
OK 這個跟大家講
股怪教授說他今天出清正2怎麼看
哲哲看比較長一點
我要6萬點
我要讓你們知道哲哲的厲害
明年6萬點
最晚明年6萬點
我認為啦 好不好 OK嗎
投資長對台塑 對鈺創
你們真的當我超人喔
什麼股票都問我
參加會員比較實在好不好
不要問那麼遠的啦
跟我的股票沒關係
不要問了啦 好不好
緯穎怎麼建議買
緯穎還不錯啦
其實我覺得AI伺服器都可以看
信昌電喔
國巨就跟他一起輪動的 好不好
看一集少一集沒問題
有那種詐騙集團說
哲哲你推薦群創
我沒有推薦他
我大概只有講過一次而已吧
是詐騙
那不是推薦喔 是詐騙喔
IG跟Threads他們最厲害
看起來好像是我的帳號
上面還有一個對話框
s178178的帳號
結果說要參加這個社群 LINE群
我沒有LINE群喔
我沒有LINE的社群喔
沒有什麼你一句 我一句
然後推薦哲哲
沒有 你懂嗎
沒有LINE的群組
我只有LINE@
LINE@在你眼裡
看起來就是一對一而已
我沒有什麼多對一的這個東西
LINE@s178
不是這個就絕對是詐騙好不好
除非是你
這個比較遠一點
我的進階會員
然後有給一個管理室的一個VIP群組
這個扯遠了
因為大部分人不是這個
不需要知道這個東西
我再講一次
一切都以LINE
一切以我這個講的話為主
不然就是以我這個講的話為主
s178178 好不好
其他的都是詐騙 OK嗎
我講了 剛才說VIP的管理室
我也不會私底下洩漏出去
在網路上面
網路上面你只要看到
Threads IG或LINE
不是這些帳號
就百分之百是詐騙
臉書我已經放棄了
沒關係 詐騙集團很厲害
把我的臉書殲滅了
沒有關係
反正我的臉書全部通通都是假的
只要有關我的通通都是假的 OK嗎
只要有郭哲榮的官方帳號
通通都是假的
記得這些東西 好不好
OK 來
現在已經不單純詐騙了
還會有人偽造你的圖喊某一檔股票
我知道詐騙集團很厲害
都把我叫出來 讓我回應
回了以後我發現
這不對 這是假帳號
來 升息美債會跌嗎
美債你不要理他
你美債換掉他好不好
美債沒前途好不好
美債我賠錢就好了好不好
你再不換掉 你問我美債我不理你
就換掉他 好不好 OK
來 群聯反彈50%
可以先出一趟等拉回再買嗎
群聯沒有50%啊
你說等群聯反彈50%的時候是不是
等群聯反彈50%反而不能
反而要繼續抱
代表突破這一波前高了
你懂我的意思嗎
代表突破這一波前高了 是
你說今天 今天好像快50%我不確定
反正真的再一次
突破2325元對不對
突破這一波高點對不對 對
要抱著
因為今天是爆一個超大量的黑K
這麼好的EPS都這樣子
我覺得有點太誇張了
原來你的臉書沒有
因為一直被詐騙集團檢舉 OK
不要在這偷罵摩爾其他分析師
不要罵其他分析師 好不好
OK嗎
哲哲也不會特別罵同業其他分析師
好不好 OK嗎
摩爾的分析師
都經過我們的品質驗證
好不好 OK
微星怎麼看
禾伸堂下禮拜會不會漲
你要不要問我禮拜一要不要漲啊
你要不要問我9點5分要不要買
問那麼仔細
沒有Fu的時候不要問我
你說兩個禮拜內會不會漲大於跌
還跌大於漲
我說應該OK
好不好 OK
哲哲 微星呢
我們看一下微星喔 來
我都直接跟你們互動反應耶
微星怎麼看
微星沒怎麼看
微星這一波根本沒跌啊
那有可能當沖的人
隔日沖的人很狠嘛
知道是少數創新高
所以現在仁寶也這樣子
這種仁寶跟技嘉
現在追高好麻煩 你懂不懂
所以不要追高
你看 微星一追高又不行了
因為他是少數創新高的股票
又不行了
技嘉也是一樣啊 是不是
2376是不是
也是一樣啊
你說這邊追高好不好
不要 抱著就好
為什麼不要追高
為什麼不要買技嘉 不要買仁寶
聽清楚喔
不要買技嘉 不要買仁寶
不要買什麼 那個微星
你們知道為什麼嗎 為什麼
因為它是少數創新高的股票
很可能這些創新高的股票
只是當沖的主力或中實戶
故意吸引大家
看噴出第一根嘛
它隔天就走掉了
你不知道 你真的很難做
那為什麼現在不要追新高
第一個 現在盤勢不穩
連最強EPS的群聯都會殺下去
盤勢不穩
所以不要去追高
那相反的拉回你買就最好
知道嗎 是
所以還是一樣
用位階決定了不同
你懂不懂我的意思
那為什麼我說
這個創新高股票不一定要追
因為一堆股票
不好意思 群聯到現在
還是差不多打
大概打7折多
7折多你知道嗎
他從288 這邊打7折
還跌30%你知道嗎
所以我要告訴大家
你幹嘛要去追一個
假設我群聯 我已經突破這邊新高
你幹嘛去追他
你聽得懂嗎 懂
你為什麼不去找這種
還在跌很慘的股票
反彈並不有力的股票
或是中美晶
我的意思是說
現在有很多選擇
基本上台灣股市不要跌破4萬點
這些股票基本上不會跌破禮拜五啦
他不會跌破前波的低點
你懂不懂我的意思
懂不懂 不會跌破這個
不是8月8
那個8月之前的
7月31號的低點 你聽得懂嗎
聽得懂我在說什麼嗎 懂
那時候台灣股市在39000
基本上除非台灣股市跌破39000
不然這些股票都不會跌破
既然不會跌破
不會到這邊那麼下面
上面的空間又是很大
你要追這種股票 中美晶這種股票
而不是我剛才說的仁寶
然後或什麼
微星或是技嘉
這一波漲最多的
是那種跌深反彈的股票
不是創新高的股票
我講的有沒有道理
所以創新高的股票你手要綁住
當沖的中實戶要玩
就讓他自己玩就好了
因為有更好的股票
跌深反彈的績優股
群聯拉回也是買
這樣懂我的意思嗎
以前我就不喜歡追高
現在更不建議追高
記得我的邏輯
今天很不錯 獨家的想法有沒有
現在幾分了
差不多要結束了
你看講一講
哲哲也是很會喇低賽
我覺得我的影片
最好應該差不多
40分結束我覺得最好 好不好
南亞科要抱著
南亞科很強
南亞科的中實戶還沒走
那就抱著 好不好
雖然我走了 好不好 OK
華新科有沒有機會
我不理你了
反正跟國巨一起看
要找我 你來找我嘛
你華新科有問題來找我好不好
對 我們今天
你看我今天沒有推專案是不是
到現在還沒推專案
我們來看一下
所以逆轉188隨時會結束
應該有可能是
週末或禮拜一結束
歡迎大家來逆轉
所以今天股票拉回你要平常心
我最後要再跟大家講一件事 來
你有問題 你有困擾
你知道嗎
你被套牢的股票
我要告訴大家
有時候套牢不是真愛
只是你不甘心而已
分清楚什麼是套牢
什麼不是套牢
我來幫你分清楚
最後我要告訴大家 來
真愛值得長抱
爛股只會長期的套牢
對不對 沒有錯吧 沒錯
誰分得清楚這是真愛還是爛股
我來幫你分清楚 OK嗎
所以你去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
逆轉188專案
不論對或錯哲哲一切的一切預告在前面
今天好多EPS很不錯的
廣達 鴻海
廣達財報那麼好
然後連那個群聯那麼好
本益比這麼低
你說台股有泡沫
去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
台灣股市沒有泡沫
很快今年就會上5萬點
明年很快就6萬點
明年有可能上半年上6萬點
我先跟你講
上半年之前
今年拚一下 比較難啦
可是今年會上5萬點
明年很快就會6萬點
不論對或錯哲哲一切的一切預告在前面
逆轉188專案
歡迎來電洽詢0800668085
或者加我的LINE私訊我
然後跟哲哲說
哲哲我要參加會員 哲哲會費多少
我竭盡所能來幫你賺大錢
今年我們5萬點見
哲哲的台灣50已經1億
馬上就賺了1300萬
不是 1500萬
差不多1500萬
已經賺1500萬
我還要賺更多
但是我最想要的是
幫你賺更多
預祝大家能夠賺大錢
Byebye